she was a feminist to me
maybe perhaps there's a perhaps
technically philosophically you disagree
with that whatever but
the you know that to me represented
strong like she had the some of the
strongest female characters in the
history of literature
again this is this is a woman running a
railroad in 1957.
and not just a woman running a railroad
this is true the fountainhead as well
a woman who is sexually
in a sense assertive sexually open
uh this is this is not a woman who you
know this is a woman who
who embraces her sexuality
and you know sex is important in life
this is why it keeps coming up
right it's it was important to iron man
it was it's important in the novels it's
important in life
and for her one's attitude towards sex
is a reflection one's attitude towards
life and you know
what attitude towards pleasure which is
an important part of life and she
thought that was an incredibly important
thing and so
she has these assertive powerful
uh sexual women who
live their lives on their terms a
hundred percent
who seek a man to look up to yeah
now this is psychologically complex it's
more psychology than philosophy right
it's psychologically complex and
you know not my area of expertise but
this is
there's something in she would argue
there's something
fundamentally different about a male and
a woman about a male and female
psychologically in their attitude
towards one another yeah but
as a side note i say that uh i would say
that
i don't know philosophically if her
ideas about gender are interesting
i think her other philosophical ideas
are much more interesting
but reading wise like the stories it
created the tension it created
um that was pretty powerful i mean that
was that's
that's pretty powerful stuff i'll
speculate that the reason it's so
powerful is because it reflects
something in reality
yeah that's true there's a thread that
at least yeah and look
it's it's really important to say she i
think she was the first feminist in a
sense
uh i think in a sense the feminists have
perverted feminism
into something that it shouldn't be but
in the sense of
men and women are capable
she was the first one who really put
that into a novel and showed it
to me as a as a as a boy when i was
reading ella shrugged i think i read
that before fountain head
that was one of the early introductions
at least if an american woman had
examples in my own life for russian
women
but of like a badass lady like i admire
like i love engineering i love that that
she could
you know here's a lady that's running
the show so
that at least to me was an example of a
really strong woman
you